so Freunde da sind wir zurück auf
unserer kleinen bumsinsel den Creeper
lassen wir da vorne einfach mal ein
Creeper sein oh mein Gott mir wird
direkt wieder schlecht in diesem Boot
wir haben für das heutige Ziel zwei
große Ziele Sprachen lnen bel denn als
allererstes möchte ich da
vorne eine kleine Farm machen weil wir
so ein minimales Hungerproblem haben und
dann möchte ich auch noch in die Mitte
von unserer Insel einen Brunnen hier
hinsetzen der dann so ein bisschen so
Mittelpunkt darstellen soll deswegen
eine ganz kurze time wie ich erstmal das
ganze Holz hier
abbaue so Freunde das ganze Holz ist
abgebaut dadurch haben wir jetzt auch
noch ein bisschen mehr essen hier vorne
ist ein Apfel und hier ist ein Apfel die
hau ich mir auch oh wir haben
Ei ist aus dem Ei gerade eine Fackel
rausgekommen da wir so ein kleines
Hungerproblem haben werde ich hier vorne
jetzt auch mal das ganze Gras abbauen in
der Hoffnung dass wir irgendwie ein
bisschen das hier da rausbekommen für
eine Farm benötigen wir allerdings nicht
nur Weizenkörner sondern auch eine
Hacke Minecraft Rezepte sind so stumpf
ne schreibt mal unten in die Kommentare
was eurer Meinung nach das dümmste
crafting Rezept ist weil das ergibt ja
wirklich teilweise überhaupt keinen Sinn
hier vorne kriegen wir dann noch
Weizenkörner raus hier nichts hier
nichts so oder so haben wir
drei
wow
wow also das wird ja die bodenloseste
faren die ich in minecraft dir gesehen
habe ja das
war's ich würde allerdings sagen dass
wir jetzt auch kurz
[Applaus]
schla nein nein oh mein Gott mein Bett
ist ja noch auf der anderen
Seite mach schneller
nein ach du
scheiße man geh mir mein scheiß Schwert
wo ist er oh er
sieh oh mein Gott oh mein
Gott
da ist ein Skelett ist sonst no
irgendwer das ist das Schaf ist da vorne
wer drumrum ne nur ein anderes Schaf der
sieht mich nicht Bo wir nehmen direkt
unsere Sachen und verziehen uns ist hier
vorne noch was drin ja wir haben noch
eisener ich krieg halben herzinf ich
hoffe das kommt rüber in den Youtube
Videos weil das Problem ist ja so ein
bisschen dass ich das hier alles
komplett in Virtual Reality sehe Leute
hier das ist doch nicht sein Ernst wo
wir allerdings gerade schon hier vorne
auf dem Festland sind können wir auch
noch mal eben kurz runter zu der Höhle
gehen denn ich hatte in der letzten
Aufnahme gesehen übrigens danke für euer
ganzes Feedback ne wir haben auch voll
viele geschrieben Luca wenn ihr schlecht
wird mach doch das POV ein bisschen
höher das Problem
ist das geht hier nicht guck mal hier
das kann man hier nicht einstellen bei
Virtual Reality also dass das so ein
bisschen breiter ist das geht halt
leider nicht aber natürlich auch ein
riesiges Dankeschön für euren extrem
riesigen Support mal wieder wirklich
sehr sehr schön sich eure ganzen
Kommentare Bo Diamant Lapis luli es war
wirklich sehr schön sich eure ganzen
Kommentare durchzulesen ihr hab das
Projekt ja wirklich sehr sehr doll
gefeiert bish her den ganzen Start wird
auch nicht so lang gehen denke ich weil
ich halt nur 100 Tage hier in dem
Projekt überleben möchte und übrigens
auch an alle die das meinten das sind
keine Diamanten Leute alles dumme
arschlecher guck mal hier vorne ist das
Skelett gestorben das auch ganz gut dann
haben wir direkt ein bisschen
Knochenmehl was wir auf unsere Farm
anwenden können wir können uns auch noch
mal hier vorne eben ein bisschen wolle
mitnehmen und bei dem Kollegen hier
vorne auch haben wir noch ein Setzling
am Start hier haben wir noch ein
bisschen Erde am Start und noch ein
bisschen Holz benötigen wir auch gleich
alles für unseren Ofen für unser
Brunnen da brauchen wir auch noch ein
bisschen Steine zunächst jedoch brauchen
wir die za den Mittelpunkt von unserer
Insel ich würde mal sagen das ist so
also muss nicht ganz genau stimmen ich
würde mal sagen das ist so grob hier
ungefähr s dass wir hier dann quasi
unseren Brunnen hinbauen denn ich möchte
dass das so der Mittelpunkt wird
oh moin der Brunnen soll der Mittelpunkt
der Insel werden s dass wir dann da
vorne unsere Farm haben die noch ein
bisschen tatsächlich ausbaufähig ist
allerdings dann hier vorne unsere kleine
Hütte dann hier irgendwie ein paar Tiere
oder so so dass wir einfach uns hier
niederlassen wo wir keinen Stress mit
Monstern haben deswegen habe ich auch
die Steine jetzt nicht da hinten geholt
sondern hier weil mir dieses festlat
nicht ganz geheuer
[Musik]
ist so Freunde ich habe jetzt hier unten
mal so ein bisschen was ausgehölt ich
stze jetzt einfach mal eine Fackel rein
Lapis l habe ich auch noch gefunden kann
ich allerdings nicht abbauen weil ich
noch eine steinspitzhacke habe und keine
eisenspitzhacke ich baue mich jetzt
erstmal hoch das werden wir natürlich
demnächst alles hier unten noch schön
säuberlich auf unsere deutsche almanart
und Weise zuauen jetzt allerdings nicht
weil mir dafür noch die Ressourcen so
ein bisschen fehlen zu allererst
benötigen wir natürlich Steine um diese
Steine dann weiter zu verarbeiten zu
steinziegeln ihr wisst ich liebe
Steinziegel wir verarbeiten unsere
Steine allerdings nicht in der crafting
Bench hier also der Werkbank weiter
sondern machen uns dafür eine Steinsäge
da wir jetzt jedoch erstmal hier vorne
auf den Ofen warten müssen würde ich
sagen da die Sonne auch schon wieder
untergeht können wir schlafen
gehen du kannst no nacht schlaf ist noch
nicht Nacht
guck mal da könen wir uns auch einmal
kurz den Sonnenuntergang
anschauen es ist schon wundervoll
ne für mich in Virtual Reality ist es
halt krass ich nehme halt viel mehr drum
rum war als ihr also ihr seht quasi nur
so ein ganz kleinen Bereich von dem was
ich sehe aber ich alter ich kann ja
sogar die Sachen anfassen Wahnsinn aber
gut okay die Sonne ist untergegangen
dementsprechend legen wir uns
schlafen
[Musik]
wir kommen heute richtig gut voran und
während unser Stein hier vorne brätt
kann ich euch schon mal zeigen wie der
Brunnen aussehen soll denn das hier ist
ja unser Mittelpunkt der Insel so grob
geschätzt ne davon müssen wir ein Z D
Blöcke zu jeder Seite gehen und dann
hier drum herum so einen Eichenlaub
Kreis bauen der komplette Bereich hier
drinnen muss ausgehüllt
werden ich weiß nicht wie ich das auf
auf einmal mache wir setzen unter die
steinziegelstufen jetzt auf jeden Fall
normale Steinziegel hier an die Kanten
kommen dann auf jeden Fall auch noch mal
Steinziegel zack zack
[Musik]
zack so Leute ich habe jetzt hier vorne
mal kurz ein paar Bäume gepflanzt damit
wir einfach keine holzprobleme bekommen
weil ich mein Holz gerade als Brennstoff
benutze ich habe mir auch einige
Steinziegel steinziegeltreppen und noch
ein paar steinziegelstufen gemacht die
benötige nämlich dafür gleich und ich
habe hier alles ein bisschen
ausgekleistert ne hier vorne habe ich
zugemacht das Loch da hat ich jetzt
leider keinen Sand um das zu zu machen
aber das da vorne habe ich alles
zugemacht guck mal moin da allerdings
auch schon wieder Nacht wird würde ich
sagen lege ich mich jetzt kurz schlafen
und dann kümmern wir uns um den Brunnen
der
S es ist immer wieder schön zu sehen
wenn wir einen weiteren Tag geschafft
haben ne also ich meine wir können
natürlich auch 100 Tage hier überleben
aber das Ziel ist natürlich an Tag 100
das ganz auch durchzuspielen und ich
weiß noch nicht wie ich mit männerd
Drachen Virtual Reality kämpfen soll so
oder so füllen wir jetzt auf jeden Fall
die Kanten hier noch mal mit
steinziegeln werden dann hier
vorne ein kleines Podest bauen worauf
wir so eine
[Musik]
kleine Säule nach oben gehen lassen
werden und das möchte ich so ein
bisschen machen wie im alten
rum also dass ich mein Minecraft Projekt
mit alten rum Vergleich ist auch eine
Sache für sich ne es ist schon Hardcore
anstrengend in Virtual Reality was
Minecraft zu bauen Alter mir wird so
schwindelig die setzen wir jetzt nur so
als übergangsblöcke hier hin denn ich
muss runterer jetzt steck ich hier drin
fest hier an die Ecken von den
erdblöcken sollen auch Treppen hin wie
ihr gerade schon gesehen habt oh mein
Gott das ist immer so schwierig über
einen Block zu springen so oder so bauen
wir die Teile jetzt erstmal wieder ab
denn die waren natürlich nur Platzhalter
und hier in der Mitte müssen wir uns
jetzt wieder
hochbauen oh wow das ist schon
hoch ach du
scheiße hallo schreibt mal in die
Kommentare ob ich beim nächsten Part von
Minecraft wire mich mal komplett
hochbauen soll und dann ins Wasser
springen soll weil das wäre glaube ich
echt Hardcore interessant wie das auf
mich mit meinem Kopf und meinem
Schwindel wirken würde einfach so ein
Selbstexperiment in Minecraft ich crafte
mir jetzt allerdings zu guter letzt noch
mal fix einen Eimer mit dem wir dann
jetzt ans Meer gehen unds Wasser
schnappen mittlerweile habe ich die
Steuerung schon echt drauf ne allerdings
meine Damen und Herren ist jetzt auch
der Moment gekommen in dem unser Brunnen
zum Leben erwacht
[Musik]
wird und unser Weizen ist auch schon
gewachsen ey geil wir haben einiges
heute geschafft wir haben da vorne
unsere kleine craftingecke aufgebaut ich
werde mir übrigens kein großes Haus ne
habe ich gerade so beschlossen weil
dieser Brunnen hat schon so Hardcore
lang gedauert zum Glück habe ich heute
nicht
gekotzt das find ich ja immer noch am
interessantesten ne dass ich mir hier in
Virtual Reality die Sachen so krass nah
anschauen kann aber gut okay das war
part